so today I'm gonna be showing you guys
something this is an iPhone case inside
this box it's not really a case case but
it's like sort of a case edge case I
like a bumper like kind of when you go
bowling and there's bumpers and the
lanes that you can actually buy munich
at the point so this company is called
gray and they sent me this I get a lot
of requests to send iPhone cases and
people want me to show them on my
youtube channel and usually there's not
much that you can innovate with an
iPhone case this is an iPhone case that
is very expensive very very expensive it
costs more than my phone basically cost
more than my life I feel like I don't
even feel worthy that I should be
touching it what I'm gonna open it let
us unbox look at this
I feel like I'm not gonna do this
justice because they sent me this note
that is explaining what this is if the
titanium body shrouded in the PVD coat
in order to create the rose gold edition
one of only 100 available world one of
only 100 Wow Wow even graved a unique
serial number as a reminder banks
passivity Wow so Wow okay this is pretty
cool so let's put it on like on the
website they were talking about how this
is like aerospace-grade
material it is so fancy how does this
even go on will it protect my iPhone
from a drop what's in here oho look at
this you've got other little bumpers to
put on too so I guess I just try to put
this on my phone and see what happens
so I feel like this is something that I
would probably put on my phone if I'm
going out to like a red carpet really
super fancy event I like to dress my
phone up you usually worry about my
phone case more than the outfit that I'm
wearing and that sometimes backfires by
the time I get to a red carpet everyone
is looking super fancy and I'm like
priorities might are skewed yeah I guess
this just goes on like that and then
this goes on over top of it how is this
secure is it secure Oh baby wow you look
good oh yeah so the little bumpers have
other colors but I feel like the black
isn't where I wanted to I love rose gold
jewelry like it is probably my favorite
as you can tell by the decor on my body
but this looks really good and even like
the background of my phone and it looks
pretty awesome I will say that it's so
good to see my phone again it's usually
just covered in a case I mean it has a
nice little case but I can put it in
when I'm not using it what are you guys
is this crazy
does it look good I mean is it basically
jewelry from my phone this is it looks
like I have a twenty five of a hundred
of them made like you can't even say
that this doesn't look cool because it
does
[Music]
I mean it definitely looks good it's
very light so it's not like it's
weighing down my phone will it protect
it because I feel like if I drop this
there pretty snug but I guess that's
that's it I don't I don't really know
how much else I can say about it if you
guys want to check out the link in the
description I put a link to their
website huge thank you to you guys for
sending me this because I was curious I
went to the site I'm like ah gross gold
oh my heart is beating very fast
measuring measuring 70 beats per minute
to be precise the gesture of ingratitude
the views our channel we'd like to give
you a home oh I didn't read the rest of
the letter they are gonna give away an
iPhone 10 to one of you guys all you
have to do is go to their Instagram
account now but remember 28 enter the
viewer has to follow their Instagram
comment on their giveaway post and
subscribe to my channel I think that's
pretty easy this is not a sponsored
video by the way just in case you any of
you guys were like just a la banda it's
not at any chance if I can facilitate a
chance for one of you guys to win an
iPhone 10 I'm gonna take it and I'm
going to give that offer back to you
guys so good luck let me know what you
guys think of this case I think it's
pretty crazy to be honest with you I
mean that's a lot of money but again
think of this as jewelry for your phone
thank you guys for watching and good
luck I hope one of you guys win the
contest and when you do win I'll come
back to this video and let us all know
I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
we be
long enough for me